you were a kid in a play and that was
when you realized oh this is just for
fun adults are here to that you could
make money at it yeah I mean they
weren't making money at it was a
community theater show but it was with
there was dominica and then the guy who
was playing my brother was they were
both in college for theater and one day
he was backstage looking through a
backstage magazine like the newspaper
the trade paper and he was pointing it
out to me and that was the moment where
I was like oh the he's doing this as a
job like he's this is this is training
for him now but this is gonna be his
career that was the first time I was
like I mean of course we all see movies
and theater instead of growing up but
for some reason it took me knowing
someone who was going into it for me to
put together like oh that's an option
you know and so that yeah that was kind
of what sparked it the other thing that
happened with that show was the writer
of the show had been at like all the
rehearsals and and whatnot and they were
doing a tour of that show so she asked
me to play the kid on that on the tour
that went out it was like a big
discussion with my family and stuff we
finally came to the point of like okay
we'll let him try it and they decided to
go with a show that didn't have a kid
role because it was easier to tour
logistically so um but kind of getting
that encouragement as a 11 year old 10
year olds kid getting that encouragement
saying yeah you did good at that you
wanted like that step up just the vision
of that being a possibility kind of
sparked me to like me I want to pursue
this and see where it could go you know
do you remember that discussion was it
around the dinner table to remember that
day or night um I mean it was it was a
couple dead like I think it was like two
or three days and it was really my
parents having an adult conversation of
like one of us is going to have to go
with him which would mean giving up our
job for the year or whatever it is and
become a true stage parent you know it
was more so than discussing it like
adults and me sitting on the other end
of the couch being like I'm gonna do it
I wanted to do it because I was 11 their
tenor would a you know so in my mind I
there was no way I couldn't do it
because how are we gonna say no to this
mom and dad I wasn't thinking give up
your life to come on the road with me
you know so I'm sure at all it
everything works out how it's supposed
to and but that was kind of what led me
down the road of one knowing there was a
job there like that this was a possible
career into knowing I that was the
career I wanted right so maybe it was
also to knowing that okay this is going
to be his his life path yeah it's not
always an easy one I think what excited
my dad at first and then disappointed
him was a dominicano Scorsese played my
sister in that show that's Martin
Scorsese's daughter and for closing
night of the show he was supposed to fly
out to Connecticut and we were having
the cast party so he was going to come
over so my dad cooked this huge italian
feast and then he got snowed out of
Connecticut there was a huge snowstorm
like the are closing weekend and so he
never came and so my dad had spent like
the whole week before cooking this huge
feast but he thought he thought that
that was pretty cool i think that one me
some points in him being supportive you
know just even that possibility there
you